i'm gonna level with you molly opioids
have a 97
relapse rate you have gone through this
15 times
do you know what an opiate antagonist is
no
it's a shot we give you once a month
this shot essentially makes you immune
to getting high
is it safe are you kidding me now all of
a sudden your body's a temple
you have to be clean for at least a week
four more days seriously
of what we've been through i'm scared
for you whenever she's around who is
that
if i wasn't a junkie would you even ask
probably not
whenever i've decided to re-engage with
her i've always done it with my eyes
wide open so you feel like
you've run out of holes i can't do that
yes you can
you want to give up the fight mom how is
she
she sits around smoking twitching
and i am there watching her like a hawk
and pretending that i'm not
almost one day down
three more to go when you think
it's the end of the road i'm so sorry
wish i'd been around you should have
been you think it's my fault
that you're an addict
[Music]
oh my god
it just goes on and i am so sorry
that my drug addiction is so incredibly
difficult on you
sometimes i get the feeling that i don't
want to love her anymore
do you know how many times that i have
told myself that i'm not gonna steal
to get hot someday i want things to be
easier for her then i'm not gonna lose
custody
of my children to get high when you
think
[Music]
[Applause]
oh i believe what does it take to get c
and you'll never get through
i'm so sorry
if there's anyone who has the strength
to break free of this
it's you i really believe that
i'm proud of you
[Music]
you